foreign
ly after I published my book I got an
email
it said your book was the only thing
that saved me from suicide
you saved my life
now for a book about how to clean that's
sort of odd yeah
but what if a new approach to cleaning
could teach us a better approach to
treating Mental Health
I'm not an interior designer or a
lifestyle influencer I'm just a
therapist with ADHD and a February of
2020 I had my second baby
because with the first one I had some
postpartum anxiety and my husband had
just taken a very demanding job that was
going to keep him busy I developed a
meticulous postpartum plan for myself
my family would rotate in and shifts for
the first 60 days the cleaning crew
would come once a month the new moms
group would drop off dinners and my
toddler would go to preschool I was so
proud of this plan
and it ended before it even began
because 2020 is when the covid lockdowns
happened and all of that support
disappeared overnight
in a blur my days turned into
breastfeeding difficulties toddler
meltdowns and depression
the dishes stayed in the sink for days
the laundry pile reached impressive
Heights
and there was often not a path to walk
from room to room
and when I should have been catching up
on sleep I would lay in bed at night and
think to myself
I'm failing
maybe I'm not capable of being a good
mom to two kids
I decided to post a joke video on Tick
Tock one day about my house turned
disaster
foreign
shots of my clutter and my dishes and my
enchilada pan to a nice beet
sort of a Laugh to Keep from cry
situation surely and I got a comment
lazy
yeah that's stung
but I must be a glutton for punishment
because I kept posting videos about my
messy house
video after video of all of the weird
tips and tricks that I was using to try
and get it back in order while managing
my feelings of being overwhelmed and I
braced myself for more criticism
but what happened was entirely different
in the comment sections of my videos
hundreds of stories came rolling in
stories like Amanda
who after losing her baby in the second
trimester was standing frozen at her
sink because she forgot how to wash
dishes
stories like Lula whose chronic health
problems and depression made it
difficult for her to brush her teeth
story after Story of people with
depression ADHD autism burnout
bereavement all struggling with these
daily tasks
and it might seem odd to some of you
that someone could struggle with tasks
that are so simple
but are they simple
let's think about what really goes into
something like laundry everyone picture
your laundry pile right now
okay
how many clean clothes do you have left
right now can you wash tomorrow or must
it be today do you need to prioritize
pre-sort pre-treat anything did you grow
up with anybody that taught you how to
do that you're out of laundry detergent
if you work three jobs when are you
going to get to the store next so if you
get there can you afford it and if you
can afford it which one you choose and
you get it all home get it in there now
pick a setting which one I don't know
Google it
by the way you have memory problems so
you'll remember that wash in about three
days when it's mildewed into the washer
it's okay it's okay just re-wash it okay
and get it into the dryer you'll forget
that too and it'll wrinkle now dry it
again
now all you have to do is get it out and
fold it but also you have three small
children and those three small children
haven't given you a moment alone in
quite some time but when you finally get
that moment you have to decide are you
going to finish the laundry are you
going to eat a sandwich are you going to
take a nap time's up you didn't do any
of it
you stared at the wall
you have decision fatigue because the
burden of carrying a home all by
yourself has burnt you out
you see for some of you all of the steps
and the skills that go into care tasks
run on autopilot
but for millions of people the autopilot
is broken
and what's worse what if you had to do
all of that when your mom just died
or your job just fired you or you're
using every ounce of strength that you
have to just not kill yourself today
if you have access to therapy it's
unlikely your therapist will ever ask
you about your laundry
I've worked in mental health for about a
decade I've been in therapy even longer
and the only time I ever had a provider
talk to me about things like cooking and
cleaning and brushing my teeth was when
I was in a psych hospital as a teenager
yet here were hundreds of thousands of
people in my comment sections telling me
that these daily care tasks were a major
pain point in their life
and so I started to wonder
what if we started here
what if we started with these care tasks
could making daily tasks easier improve
mental health quicker
in the two years that I've been posting
and writing about the intersection of
Mental Health and Care tasks I've come
up with a philosophy that does just this
and it all starts with one simple idea
cooking
cleaning
laundry
it doesn't make you a good person
or a bad person
listen to me
care tasks are morally
neutral
now I know that if you've been watching
Martha Stewart for decades
and scrolling the perfect Pinterest
aesthetic every day
that it can feel like struggling with
these tasks is a moral failure like it's
because we're lazy or we're
irresponsible or we're immature
but having an organized closet doesn't
make you a success and living out of a
pile of laundry on the floor doesn't
make you a failure
you know where the shirt you want to
wear is it just
it might take you a bit of sifting to
find it
the truth is it's not about morality
it's about functionality
does your home work for you
not some hypothetical house guest that
is coming to inspect your closet
I mentioned Amanda who had lost her baby
and forgot how to wash dishes
she told me that when her husband would
go to work she would lay on the floor
next to the empty crib and say to
herself what can I bring to my family if
I can't even wash dishes
but that changed when she began to see
care tasks as morally neutral
all of a sudden the dishes in the sink
weren't representations of her failure
as a wife but instead she would look at
the pile
and think to herself what do I need to
function tomorrow morning
and then pull two coffee cups out of the
pile to wash
she had her coffee the next morning and
it was a little bit easier to get up off
the floor
when we liberate ourselves from the idea
that we are a good person or a bad
person with care tasks we can stop
thinking about the right way to do
things about the way that things should
be done and instead start thinking about
what we can do with our current barriers
to improve our quality of life today
and this is the fun part because you get
to customize a life that works for you
when Lula realized that her problems
with brushing her teeth were not moral
failings she gained the confidence to
speak to her dental hygienist and
together they came up with solutions
that work around her barriers
she now relies on pre-pasted disposable
toothbrushes that she keeps in her desk
floss she keeps in the living room and a
no rinse prescription toothpaste
because by breaking down the component
parts of a dental hygiene routine and
ensuring that each step was accessible
to her mental and physical needs
for the first time in a year she's done
every step in that routine for two weeks
straight
she says that now that her teeth are
clean she's a little less stressed about
tomorrow's problems
and this approach can work with any care
task that you struggle with
simply ask yourself what am I trying to
achieve and how can I achieve it in my
way
in a rare moment of folding clothes
I looked down at the Baby Onesie that I
was folding and I thought to myself
why am I folding this
maybe once these don't really wrinkle
and even if they did nobody cares if a
baby's on a wrinkly onesie
furthermore I was probably going to
change her four times before lunch
this doesn't need to be folded
I said it out loud and literally braced
myself
for
the laundry police
I don't know there are rules to laundry
but for the first time I stopped
thinking about the way that laundry
should be done
and instead started thinking about how I
could make laundry functional for me
and I looked down at the fleece pajamas
and the underwear and the athletic
shorts and the tank tops and realize
almost none of my clothes actually
needed to be folded
and I haven't fooled any of it since
I moved all of my family's clothes into
one Closet off the laundry room and now
I just toss things into organized bins
unfolded
my new motto is good enough is perfect
and everything worth doing is worth
doing half-assed
foreign
you have to give yourself permission to
do a little
to do it with shortcuts
to do it while breaking all of the rules
and replace that inner voice that says
I'm failing
with one that says I'm having a hard
time right now
and people who are having a hard time
deserve compassion
if it's too hard to shower today grab
the baby wipes
it may not be the normal way to do it
but you deserve to be clean
if it's too hard to cook dinner
get paper plates
heat up something Frozen you'll go back
to cooking and washing another day but
the day is not today and in the meantime
you deserve to eat
if you're too depressed to do your
dishes get a two gallon Ziploc bag and
keep it in your bedroom because if you
put a dirty plate into a two gallon
Ziploc bag and seal it it will keep the
bugs away
thank you
and it'll be there for you when you're
ready to go back to the kitchen
because you deserve a sanitary
environment even if you can't get out of
bed
I could share with you hundreds of other
genius solutions that people have come
up with once they embrace the idea that
care tasks are morally neutral
in my experience people will exhibit
mind-blowing creativity
when they are only taught how to speak
compassionately to themselves
so what if mental health treatment
started here
by Shifting the idea of care tasks as
these external measurements of your
worthiness to just being morally neutral
tasks that you can customize to care for
yourself
because if it's true
that regardless of what you struggle
with you are worthy of a functional
space
what else might you be worthy of
thank you
[Applause]